réponse du telle est la question le
professionnel le professionnel qui à la
question s'il vous plaît bonsoir cas de
musique a été diffusé lors des obsèques
de jean paul belmondo aux invalides
ouais alors qu'il ya une musique de film
est sorti de circle
je donne la réponse malheureusement
avant jamais dormi là est allé comme
quoi malheureusement oui non et
heureusement parce que vient de fait à
peine nommé déjà les
chérir il y a trois jours un jour on
nous a quittés la disparition de jean
paul belmondo on sait bien sûr un
événement qui touche des millions de
français d'ailleurs toutes les chaînes
vous dit rien aujourd'hui ça leur
programmation ils ont fait des éditions
spéciales et c'est un hommage national
qui lui a été rendu on va vous montrer
le déroulé de cette cérémonie je vous en
parlais après parce que avec bernard on
a eu la chance d'y être parce que
c'était très très très émouvant
franchement très réussi et quand le
cercueil est parti avec l'américain
deuxième structure que tout le monde
s'il avait les larmes aux yeux et mêmes
des personnes qui pleurait à chaudes
larmes on va revenir sur les grands
moments bien sûr de cet hommage mais
juste bernard montiel pour les
téléspectateurs et je sais que ça les
intéresse c'est normal parce que même
moi je savais pas comment ça se passe et
de ce que j'avais fait
les obsèques de charles aznavour aux
invalides dirais que c'est la famille
directement qui m'avait demandé de venir
là c'est la famille belmont d'autres
maladies d où les personnes qui devaient
tenir d'autres comment ça se passe en
fait il y avait des personnes qui était
proposé à la famille et la famille aisée
oui mais on veut qu'il y ait c'est ça
c'est à dire que d'abord empire utc la
famille évidemment c'est quand même
leurs papilles des convives invités en
fait tu 700 dans la cour d'accord il y
avait dans les rives il y avait plus de
1000 personnes la colas était qu'ils
voulaient venir que les arbitres et 7
700 en accord avec la famille donc voila
et l'elysée il y avait un côté il y
avait la famille oui à toute la famille
oui il y avait un autre côté il y avait
les personnes qui étaient mes
journalistes au dessus c'est vrai et le
protocole imposé en revanche qui élément
du gouvernement qui souhaitait venir
évidemment tout le monde est venu alors
qu'ils nous le gouvernement a vu c'était
très bien d'accord
jean castex d'accord jean castex était
là le prémunit s'il y avait eu rose hill
bachelot france charlie
gabriel atteint tout le monde tous les
ministres étaient là et y avait au
milieu la famille comme on a pu le voir
à la télévision et les 700 et les autres
400 personnalités tout le monde du
cinéma étaient réunis les plus grands
noms du cinéma était là il y avait jean
dujardin bien sûr en l'art avec nathalie
qui a un amour de mecs étaient
bouleversés jean dujardin c'est un mec
tu ne le faudrait
oui c'est vrai dit adorable il était
souriant enfin même là ils étaient très
touchés mais il a toujours le mot gentil
les jours c'est vrai avec
beaucoup il le sait donc je connais
c'est vraiment un mec qui n'a pas changé
dans tes sacs et le tout ça il n'a pas
changé du tout malgré le succès malgré
tout ce qui lui arrive et je le voyais
jean dujardin tout à l'heure et c'est
vrai que il est vraiment il a une
stature maintenant ah oui internationale
c'est incroyable il est magnifique un
oscar quand même un non mais vraiment et
il se prend pas la tête il est génial et
zain et sa femme et est très simple et
nathalie était bouleversée à la plus
réactionnaire c'est vrai oui de jean
nathalie péchalat qu'il a pu prétendre
maintenant du du patinage artistique
alors donc comment ça se passe en fait
qui décide alors donc comme je le disais
c'est la famille d'abord un accord avec
l'elysée évidemment ils proposent des
noms il propose la famille donne des
normes qui va là il y avait notamment
le garde du corps de jean paul c'était
très émouvant parce qu'il est il était
un peu fatigué le jo que tout le monde
connaît quand on a connu belmondo
c'était son chauffeur garde du corps qui
avait déjà fêté là ce soir pour la
spéciale dans un voilà il y avait rachid
ci a certes fait rage qui sera là aussi
je crois ce soir matignon le petit
garçon de la caf leur ai tout ça c'est
comment ça se passe c'est à dire c'est
quoi commencer la famille qui dit et
c'est l'élysée kravitz et c'est l'elysée
qui s'en occupent qui envoie à tout le
monde de la mode donc vous avez reçu on
reçoit un scénarisé l'elysée au l'elysée
voilà absolument et vous direz vous
demande ces milliers
à la cérémonie pour vous voulez assister
ou pas attends ça c'est le passé ni
terre à temps vous avez le bon ouais
mais j'ai le mot je les gardais à esi je
vais me le faire dédicacer alors vrai
alors l'invitation de monsieur le
président de république hommage national
rendu à monsieur jean paul belmondo
monsieur emmanuel macron président d'un
public prie monsieur montiel de bien
vouloir assister à la cérémonie
d'hommage voilà et ça il fallait
répondre c'est à dire que quand vous
recevez d'abord le sms il fallait
répondre par mail obligatoirement c'est
invitation point l'elysée at elysee.fr
bref et là il faut que vous aviez
accepté enfin vous dites oui vous
confirmez votre présence on vous envoyer
ce mail là il fallait avoir se mêla à
l'entrée c'est extrêmement réglementé
présenter le maître présenter le pas
salutaire et porter le masque voilà
hélas passible ce en fonction du grade
alors c'est qu'on l'a pas si tu as
raison la pastille bleue effectivement
la passe il se sait les artistes
d'accord c'est le monde c'est le monde
du cinéma pour vous
parler d'eux qu'ils avaient une possible
aussi cyril à vervant estime la même fac
parce que j'étais sorti ma part je suis
toujours à côté de la plaque voilà j'ai
je n'avais pas le truc que l'on vous a
reconnu surtout vd la vérité j'avais pas
le bail doit y avait pas le feu n'était
à côté de bob sinclar
grimace la chanteuse ça va mon ami
christophe dechavanne et c'est vrai que
alors regardez il y avait énormément de
gens de personnalités du monde de la
culture du cinéma du sport sont
retrouvés pour l'hommage rendre hommage
à l'as des as regardé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est vrai qu'il y avait
énormément de monde on n'a pas pu tous
ces systèmes il y avait énormément
d'émotion et ensuite vous le dis vous
êtes donc aux invalides et là à un
moment vous sentez que tout le monde se
tait parce que il ya l'arrivée du chef
de l'état emmanuel macron qui est venu
avec brigitte voilà et donc il ya le
président de la république qui fait son
entrée dans les invalides et là vous
vous sentez tout le monde se tait
regardez emmanuel macron qui était
accompagné du premier ministre castex
mais qui est derrière lui en fait ça se
passe comme ça toujours supporté une
marche devant en éclaireur et jean
castex voilà il est derrière au cas où
quant au col c'est le protocole c'est
comme ça pour te colle toujours
répétition avant parce que moi je me
suis dit j'ai vu le chef de l'état j'ai
vu manuel mâcon il savait qu'il fallait
aller la savais qu'il fallait aller l'a
ensuite il répète pas du tout non quand
on y regarde bien non vers la prison la
république arrive avec castex derrière
castex après se retire c'est normal il
est chef du gouvernement les protocole
impose aux prises en république et il le
fait toujours et beaucoup de plaisir de
saluer tous les corps armés qui étaient
présents parce qu'il a reçu la grande
croix à belmondo donc c'est tout les
l'armée de terre la marine toutes les
armes et lui ont rendu hommage et donc
le président va d'abord saluer tout le
groupe ensuite il va retrouver de son
épouse et c'est là que les petits
enfants deux exécutions belmondo ont
parlé en garde regardez l'arrivée des
médias
[Musique]
ans
ça
voilà alors donc là c'est l'arrivée du
chef de l'état donc à une première
marseillaise que la marseillaise était
joué plusieurs fois je vous dis une fois
la cérémonie commence et c'est pas le
chef de l'état qui a d'abord fait le
discours c'est d'abord la famille a été
appelée donc au pupitre pour faire un
discours notamment les petits enfants et
c'est victor belmondo son petit fils que
j'adore c'est un garçon qui a un talent
exceptionnel qui va être un comédien
déjà exceptionnel qui va je vous dis
tout cartonner xandre essaierait qui lui
ressemble gauck c'est incroyablement
avec c'est un garçon d'une gentillesse
et d'un talent immense et je pense qu'il
va cartonner victor regarder il a été
magnifique un vraiment dans finissent
pas dans les boules vieille maman poule
avec les petits-enfants de jean-pierre
regarde là où il est je suis sûr et
certain qu'ils sourient comme toujours
et qu'il est pleinement heureux de cet
hommage
heureux aussi de voir à quel point les
français et lui témoigne de leur amour
lui qui les aimait tant merci papy
de nous avoir donné tant de joie merci
d'avoir temps partagé la positivité
tu nous laisses rempli de ce bonheur
immense on pense à toi on t'aime
et amusé trop bien avec tes copains qui
sont en manque est
resté victor le petit-fils donc le jean
paul belmondo et je vous le dis la
famille et est incroyable c'est vraiment
une très belle famille son exemple est
très très belle femme l'amant
exceptionnel je voudrais de rome
j'essaie des gens incroyables et il
était il était vraiment vraiment une
moyenne de cesser ces fous ils
s'entendent bien ils sont mignons et
d'ailleurs regarder à côté de victoria
stella oui la fille la fille de natty
qui est là aussi qu'est ravissante qui
auraient éventuellement à sa mère la
tique est toujours magnifique aussi
toujours oui il ya la fille de florence
aussi en fins et c'était très émouvant
c'est une famille très unie très aimante
ce sont vraiment des gens bien vraiment
c'est des gens vraiment fou on essayait
de vous faire vivre un hommage à jean
paul beugnot parce qu'on a eu la chance
d'y aller avec avec bernard c'était très
important vraiment un mauvais mois d'y
aller je vous savez voilà j'étais fan de
jean paul il est je le voyais très
souvent est ce soir en plus dans btp je
vous le dis au début de l'émission il ya
jeff qui était son son plus fidèle
camarade qui m'a dit que jean-paul
voulait me donner un cadeau depuis
longtemps il n'a jamais pu me le donner
et il me donnera ce soir il m'a dit ça
tout à l'heure il m'a dit je te la mare
est tout à l'heure et jean-paul voulait
donner un cadeau il voulait te le donner
cet été il n'a pas eu l'occasion de voir
il me donnera tout à l'heure élu
meilleur ces trésors je voudrais
préciser une chose beaucoup ont été
surpris par l'absence d'alain delon oui
c'est vrai il n'y avait pas alain delon
c'est ce que je me suis libre aussi oui
voilà alors je me suis renseigné pour
lui trop dur non oui ce jour là et en
plus en plein soleil je vais vous dire
que mais au delà de ça c'est qu'il était
fatigué mais en revanche il va tout
faire pour aller demain à l'hérésie
saint charles à 11 ans 11 mai à céret
qu'alain delon toutes ses demandes et
commente ses demandes et voilà si alain
delon est hélas pas là je voyais du coup
j'ai demandé d'accord une actrice très
proche qui est nicole calfan qui a
changé dans le borsalino notamment ouais
alors poursuit-il emmanuel macron a
rendu hommage à jean paul belmondo et à
sa carrière dans un discours très
émouvant très beau discours nous dit si
j'ai vu un mec un peu plus après le
trésor indiqué me voir j'ai pas pour moi
une fille c'est moi qui écris le
discours du président au logo être
savoir mec tout jeune moi l'allemagne et
ben il est très bon franchement il avoue
à lui je vous jure le discours était
bien puisque et moi ce que moi quand
j'ai écouté le président j'imagine le
président ils t'appellent de dire tu
décris un discours moi je sais c'est dur
c'est pas c'est pas évident on craint un
discours pour jean paul belmondo non
mais c'est vrai
ça prend deux minutes voilà mais c'est
vrai que pour jean paul belmondo ccm
c'est plus compliqué regarder
the town il nous faut sourire ce jour
comme vous n'avez jamais cessé de le
faire c'est parce que nous savons que
vous continuerez de nous accompagner
qu'il nous suffira pour retrouver votre
gouaille solaire de pousser la porte
d'une salle de cinéma
d'allumer une télévision un écran
alors à nouveau
la magie opérera
et depuis le siège passager d'une
voiture rose avec des étoiles vertes
nous pourront crier que finalement nous
aimons la mer nous aimons la montagne et
nous aimons la ville rien à [ __ ] voilà
adieu bébel
alors que vous essaierez que c'était on
va passer à la partie mais c'est vrai
que c'est un hommage vraiment là on
avait on n'avait plus le coeur serré oui
oui je voudrais juste préciser que le
président évidemment les faits une trame
au départ parce qu'il est tellement des
objets offerts donnez lui le faire à sa
façon comme toujours parce que d'abord
il était fan de belmondo puisqu'il a
reçu plusieurs fois l'elysée connaissez
tous les baltes où ils connaissent et où
il coulait tous les films les réponses
les lieux audiard tout ça et il tenait
vraiment lui c'est toujours lui qui
mais la dernière pato discours parce
qu'il l'aimait vraiment elle a reçu en
privé plusieurs fois l'elysée lui a
remis la grand-croix quand même voyez la
passion qu'il avait pour jean paul
belmondo et c'est vrai que voilà je vous
dis il y avait énormément d'artistes
tout le monde était très très très ému
et oui non mais vous parlez des artistes
et vous parler évidemment de ceux qui
étaient très proches mais y avait des
images incroyables 20 des gens à
l'extérieur qui ne travaillait
exceptionnelle qui est on voit la
ferveur populaire et il avait la passion
que les français allemands pour belmondo
que j'étais triste et heureux d'être là
voilà c'est un mélange à la fois de de
bonheur d'être tous ensemble et dorée de
rire jouer à la pétanque avec l'aide de
lassos lui j'avais pas de jouer j'y
crois
très digne c'était vraiment que je pense
comme jean nouvel aurait voulu que ce
soit oui il ya un silence incroyable
quand même un respect total beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup de pleurs beaucoup
d'émotion et on est tous sortis de là
que c'est vrai comme sonnés et lui qui
aimait bien les gens et qui refusait
jamais comme on a vu dans les docks dans
le dock de ses huit hier des interviews
les autographes il refusait jamais de
passer du temps avec les gens moi j'ai
trouvé une super idée vraiment et si
j'avais pu j'aurais été à 19h30
n'importe quel lambda vous pouvez y
aller parce que c'est bien parce qu'il y
avait les voeux des leurs ex d'argent
maintenant vous avez pu y aller mais en
ce moment même je vous mets tu veux
aller là bas jean matte et avancer avec
fenêtre parisien c'est relou mais au
moins tu peux aller voir jean paul
belmondo et dire au revoir au cercueil
de jean paul belmondo et ça se trouvait
initiative je trouve ça vraiment génial
parce que belmondo scène publique alors
regardez ensuite c'était très très fort
en émotion de ce passage de la cérémonie
c'est le passage où vraiment tout le
monde a eu les larmes aux yeux bernard
montiel rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la famille qui a voulu que ce soit
à la garde républicaine et c'était un
moment je vous jure quand on était
là-bas quand il ya eu cette musique qui
a retenti le cercueil qui est parti
vraiment on a tous été pris dans une
émotion qu'elle ait baha normale dans
leurs voyants c'est une choix de jean
paul ince c'est vrai j'étais j'étais à
côté de gilles lellouche à côté de jean
dujardin uri et voyez à côté de nathalie
aussi mona péchalat c'est vrai que tout
le monde je vous dis était dans une
émotion incroyable tout le monde avait
les larmes aux yeux il y avait également
jean-claude un d'armes ont quitté son
insolence et proches aussi qui était qui
était vraiment aussi très très ému et
richard anconina et c'est vrai que je
vous dis les jaunes on se parlait même
pas entre eux c'est vrai que j'aimerais
vraiment chacun était dans sa bulle
regarder vraiment ce qui se passait et
il n'y avait pas de g voilà j'ai dû
assister à des cérémonies comme ça les
gens parlent entre eux et ces voix là
bas il y en a pas un qui a sorti son
téléphone pour regarder un truc un lapin
enfin après je vous dis il ya beaucoup
même de personnalités ces fous qui ont
filmé la dernière scène qui ont sorti
leurs portables juste à ce moment là
pour filmer le départ du cercueil de
jean-paul belmondo et c'est vrai que
voilà les gens qui se parlent entre eux
et ils étaient tous dans leur bulle et
il regardait tous voilà ce qui se
passait plutôt vers le sol n'y avait pas
de l'agitation c'était très très calme
et il y avait un silence incroyable
c'est vrai dans un élégant et c'était
c'était encore plus fort d'ailleurs
parce que pas un maul étaient tous au
nez on se regarde et on se reconnaissait
bien surtout sentir sur rien croit pas
un mot la détresse la peine votre ou
externe bel hommage pour à oui j'ai
trouvé les gants comme comme cette
famille c'était à l'image de cette
famille c'est à l'image cette famille
délicatesse élégance amour beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup de la bourse regardez
ils sont tellement mignons tous ici
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de gentillesse
moi je les adore vraiment c'est des gens
formidables j'ai vu luân à la pauvre la
femme de jean paul ii paul qui n'est pas
le moment moi c'est le savez monsieur
qui l'embrassé jeu s'est alors regarder
s'il y avait des gens partout il y avait
jean pierre raffarin aussi qu'ils
étaient en vie que j'ai croisé un bon
bien sûr aider michel drucker et avec
françois hollande que j'ai pas croisés
ils étaient toutes au buffet
non mais c'est vrai que françois
hollande également qu'ils étaient là ils
peuvent y avait pas nicolas sarkozy non
parce que oui mais moi je vais vous dire
nicolas sarkozy je le comprends ils
connaissaient pas apparemment pas très
bien
jean paul belmondo et c'est vrai qu'il
n'avait rien à y faire au moins c'est
quelqu'un qui touchent pas à mine de
rien mais cet ancien président pouvait
être l'or et du tout non mais là le
national a le protocole abrite le
dernier président il c'est françois
hollande on assure donc le poteau on
devait inviter françois baroin ouais
ouais il est obligé il y avait un nid
d'algos également oui votre ami c'est
vrai vous à chercher n'a pas trouvé non
mais c'est vrai gars il y avait donc à y
avait un hidalgo également peu elle est
d'ailleurs il a salué c'est normal aussi
de la saluer c'est le protocole a dit au
début comme il est alors je vous dis
c'est très c'est très bizarre au départ
et là je voulais vous poser une question
grave parce que vous allez réagir vous
aussi c'est que le président de la
république en commençant son discours
dit monsieur le premier ministre donc il
salue monsieur premier run and bike ai
dit monsieur le président ils sont au
salut non maintenant il salue hollande
n'est pas là c'était pour fausse mais
sinon je crois il s'auto salut non non
il salue françois hollande
si on va croiser quand vous allez
recroiser françois hollande avait
beaucoup de bonheur au buffet vous
pourrez lui dire bonjour monsieur le
président à la noix que les coins du
gîtas pas faim
on les rappelle présent ou chargeant pas
vers les anciens ministres je vais leur
dire mais monsieur le ministre les
anciens premiers ministres vous dites
monsieur premier ministre alain juppé
monsieur le premier ministre il a écouté
et franchement vous avez protocole
j'étais sûr voilà que voilà le président
de l'aso tous
les chiffres de gaza était une
magnifique cérémonie on voulait la faire
vous voulez vous la faire vivre ce sens
il faut dire que juste avant parce que
les gens n'ont peut-être pas vu il y
avait toutes les images des films et
toutes les musiques des films et y'avait
maladie mercos makita québec acq a
composé toutes les films etc toutes les
milices de films de surf le
professionnel non à gauche sauf le
professionnel
morricone et l'émir cosma qui je crois
que ça chez vous ce soir aussi m'at-il
dit ça ce soir oui il sera avec vous
aussi il a été très élégant pas ce que
tu dit vladimir ça te plaise pas qu il
ait choisi le professionnel mais non
c'est la plus belle musique qui soit ça
voilà l'élégant du mec alors qu'il a
fait des musiques extraordinaire il
était même pas pour le professionnel
cette musique à la base elle est sorti
dix ans avant et ils ont repris pour le
professionnel celui qui n'est en fait je
vous dis vraiment de l'émotion et de
l'airé un très très bel hommage et
c'était mérité pour lille en pole à qui
on avait encore ce soir dans la balance
ton post exceptionnel et j'ai hâte de
savoir le cadeau que je vous dis qui m'a
jamais donné donc jeff voilà son plus
fidèle camarade me le donnera tout à
l'heure il m'a dit ah vrai cadeau c'est
pour ça qu'ils voulaient devenir
soi-même je veux faire l'émission
balances ton poste ce soir parce que
voilà je veux te voir juste avant parce
que je veux te donner un truc que
jean-paul voulait donner et il dit que
ça ça te représente bien il m'a dit tu
donneras ça à cyril voilà et il a été
très importante dans l'organisation je
vois aussi il a tourné un peu dans tous
les sens pour placer untel
arielle dombasle etc il a fait tout le
tour il a et c'est vraiment bien occupés
de tout le monde voilà et ses rivages et
surtout jean dujardin très émue et
gilles lellouche aussi labé en larmes
ont été cités à vernon l'argent du
jardin gilles lellouche dans le dans le
discours est absolument baisses étaient
les plus proches qu'ils ont tourné
ensemble c'est vraiment les plus proches
on était la bande de copains allaient
dernier copains écouter mais en tout cas
c'est un bien bel hommage